-Welcome to "The Tonight Show,"
everybody!
That's a crowd right there.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Welcome.
Thank you for watching.
Well, let's get
to some news, guys.
This is big.
Apparently President Biden
is seriously considering
canceling student-loan debt.
[ Cheers and applause ]
When asked how the country
can afford it, Biden said,
"I'm gonna slide into
Elon Musk's DMs."
[ Laughter ]
Yep, Biden wasn't
even thinking about forgiving
student-loan debt until
he looked at his poll numbers
with young voters.
"And your debt will be forgiven.
Perfect."
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, Biden's basically
telling every college student,
"I'll take care of
your four years
if you take care of mine,
you know?"
[ Laughter ]
It's a risky move for Biden.
He's about to win over everyone
with student loans, and lose
everyone who just paid them off.
Like, "You gotta be kidding me!"
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile,
today at the White House,
Biden hosted the 2022
Teachers of the Year.
Yeah. Biden honored the
Teachers of the Year,
while over in the next room,
they honored the
Substitute of the Year
by putting on a movie.
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Hold on."
[ Applause continues ]
At the ceremony, Biden awarded
the national Teacher of the Year
a glass apple.
The teacher was like, "That's
cool, but how about a raise?"
[ Laughter ]
It was a great event
for the teachers,
but it was super-awkward after
when Biden
ran into them
at the grocery store.
[ Laughter ]
"Ah!
Can't see you outside of --
You have a husband?"
[ Laughter ]
Some business news --
I read that if Elon Musk
backs out of the Twitter deal,
he'll have to pay
a $1 billion termination fee.
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
Yeah.
A billion-dollar
termination fee --
it's pretty much the same deal
as leaving Planet Fitness.
[ Laughter ]
Some entertainment news --
Today at CinemaCon in Las Vegas,
13 years after the original
"Avatar" hit theaters,
viewers were treated to a first
look at James Cameron's sequel
"Avatar: The Way of Water."
Yeah, 13 years.
That's a long time.
Now the characters are so old,
they have "the way of water"
three times a night.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, the characters are so old,
they're now blue
because of poor circulation.
That's -- That's what I mean.
[ Laughter ]
Speaking of big movies,
it was just announced
that Robert Pattinson's gonna
return for a sequel
of "The Batman."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yes!
That's right.
Eccentric billionaire
who tries to solve the world's
problems by himself.
Spoiler alert --
he just buys Twitter.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, this is pretty cool.
Scientists have created
genetically modified lettuce,
that can keep astronaut's bones
from crumbling
on their trip to Mars.
Yeah.
When asked their opinion on it,
here's what several astronauts
had to say.
This first astronaut said...
[ Laughter ]
This next astronaut said...
Next astronaut said...
[ Laughter ]
And finally,
this last astronaut said...
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Cymbal crashes ]
This is kind of a weird story.
In Alabama,
after raw chicken parts
were spilled all over the road,
police told people to drive
carefully and hold their nose.
Take a look at this.
Ew.
[ Audience groans ]
People are like, "What did you
think we were gonna do?
Pull over and breathe deeply?
I mean, what do you --"
[ Laughter ]
Sadly, now we know what happened
when the chicken
crossed the road.
[ Laughter ]
Guys, I saw that a train in
Argentina had to be delayed
after a man fell asleep
across two seats
and got his head stuck
under the metal armrest.
Take a look at this.
[ Laughter ]
Laugh all you want, but that's
first class on Spirit Airlines.
Ah, you know.
[ Laughter ]
That's the way to go.
Get your head in there.
Hey, I heard about a 13-year-old
boy who's about to graduate
from the University of Minnesota
with a bachelor's degree
in physics.
Yeah, you can tell he's super
smart, 'cause he's graduating
just in time to have
his student loans forgiven.
Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Smart -- Smart kid.
And, finally, it is time to take
a look at the stories
making headlines today
and weigh the good with the bad.
It's time for "Pros and Cons."
Here we go.
-♪ Pros and cons and pros
and cons and pros ♪
-Tonight, we'll be taking a look
at the pros and cons
of legalizing weed
in New Jersey.
That's right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
As of last week,
people in New Jersey
can now buy
recreational marijuana,
so let's take a look
at the pros and cons
of legalizing weed
in New Jersey.
Here we go.
Pro -- saying "Fuhgeddaboudit."
[ Laughter ]
Con -- then actually
forgetting about it.
[ Laughter and applause ]
"What was I supposed
to remembabout?"
[ Laughter ]
Pro -- the marijuana bill
was tough to pass.
Con -- it was much easier
to puff-puff-pass.
There you go.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Pro -- people will quickly go
from this...
con -- to this...
There you go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Pro -- a short, tan joint
in New York is called a blunt.
Con -- a short, tan joint in
New Jersey is called a Snooki.
Oh, interesting.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Rim shot ]
Pro -- smoking before
catching a long flight.
Con -- bringing
a whole new meaning to
"taking the red-eye
out of Newark."
It's like yeah.
[ Applause ]
Pro --
getting stoned in Bayonne.
Con -- then playing hacky sack
in Hackensack.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Pro -- people in New Jersey
already know
how to roll a joint.
Con -- it's like rolling up
a body in a carpet but smaller.
Hey.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Whoa.
Pro -- New Jersey may introduce
many weed-themed businesses.
Con -- like the new social club
the Bada Bong!
[ Laughter and applause ]
And finally, pro --
less "Ay! Oh!"
Con -- more like, "Hey, whoooa!"
That's the "Pros and Cons,"
everybody.